hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen spielprinzip und zwar hält
dieses spielprinzip support und diese
grad schon mittendrin ich habe das bei
sky das minecraft gesehen
und zwar muss man so lange wie möglich
auf dieser plattform sein wie es geht
ich bin im welche farbe welches team
habe ich weiß gar nicht welches team ich
habe ich bin im roten team glaub ich bin
ich im roten team
ich bin im blauen team und ich muss die
roten jetzt quasi sich ein team in dem
blauen team muss die roten hier von der
fläche runter kicken und zwar über leben
halt nur die die am ende immer noch hier
drauf sind deswegen ist jetzt erst mal
runter es wäre mal schwerter und wes
brown hier einfach das ist ganz einfach
schon erklärt etwas anderes ist das
eigentlich nicht so dass runter und man
musste dann halt und taktiken und es ist
halt dann so dass man bei so muss das ja
auch 2009 ich versucht man hier erklärt
man bei sumo ist das ja auch so er den
sport kennt das man gegen erkämpft zwei
leute und die müssen dann eben wie
außerhalb dieses ringes gebracht werden
und dann hat der andere dann halt
gewonnen der dann halt noch drin ist und
das ist genau hier auch der fall es gibt
verschiedene teams ich weiß gar nicht ob
das am anfang stand stand ihnen wie sumo
ist da rating von bbb standard gar nicht
also man muss halt gucken welches team
am anfang ist man das irgendwie nimmt
man muss dann irgendwie einmal kurz
jeder rücken ins blaue oder irgend sowas
nicht also man wir müssen dann halt die
anderen wenn ich glauben die man die
anderen roten runter kicken
und das ging eigentlich jetzt relativ
schnell ich würd sagen ich pack 1 warten
noch mal ein paar runden und dann sehen
wir uns sofort wieder so freunde die
nächste runde summe startet in fünf
sekunden und ich bin wieder im blauen
team-mitglieder die roten darunter kippt
das ist eine neue map atomenergie stehen
zu bleiben dass ich mich bis zum ende
ein bisschen hier durchhalten kann ich
schaffe es auch gehabt allerdings gar
nicht in mitte zu kommen
besser ist echte stellt euch ein paar
leuten in mittelstadt einfach alle
anderen drum rum weg server befindet in
der beschreibung sind die häufigsten
server ip da gibt es das nicht sondern
ist ins gerry and harry irgendwie sowas
also steht in der beschreibung auf jeden
fall könnt ihr dann auch einfach spielen
wenn ich wirklich bin wirklich gab schon
gefragt warum die kennen nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
ich glaube jetzt einfach mal wissen hier
um
ich glaube das könnte bieterrunde sein
ich glaub da könnt ihr jetzt mal was
reißen hier nummern wird dann immer wenn
man einmal getroffen klickt man auf
jeden fall des übels weit weg das ist
mal so ein bisschen suboptimal
man muss halt noch ein bisschen sobald
den teamkollegen werden
du kommst jetzt erstmal hier weg hier
gibt es hakt noch mal sind erst ein
bisschen ja dass er hier will das ist
nach einladung quasi das der hirschen
veranstaltet turtle damit ist natürlich
gute taktik bleibt ihr nicht gegen den
profi nein ich bin total schlecht in
welchen sachen das ist dieselbe auch weg
weg weg weg weg weg weg also es ist
wirklich einfach nur sinnloses darauf
umschlag mit taktik ist eigentlich
nichts aber ich denke das könnten wir
diesmal nicht reißen welche sind nur
noch relativ wenig rote gerade wie
fliegt ja auch irgendwie nicht weg das
versteht nämlich auch nicht warum manche
leute nicht wegfliegen haben die dann in
wien hätten oder werden nicht keine
ahnung ein wenig nachvollziehen wenn ich
werde einmal getroffen und bin so gut
wie tot hier weg dann einfach unter jörg
ebert gewinn war wahrscheinlich müssen
jetzt nur noch unter kicken nur etwa der
wm nicht fliegen das ist halt im weg
weiß nicht was hat talent so fliegt er
endlich egal ich habe jetzt gar nicht
mehr schwer hat acht und neun schwer
also ich verstehe es nicht wieso
sollen das wiso kanada nicht hacker alle
schreiben so wie dumm war das denn wie
kassier typ tu was können wir denn dass
wir jetzt muss die blauen diesmal unter
klicken hätte wäre das echt komisch
jetzt direkt in der nächsten runde
sofort wieder drin also das komplette
spiele eigentlich nur total sinnlos ich
denke ich jedoch keine nächste folge
mehr davon geben
aber auf diesem server kann man auch
warnende chamber spielen man kann auch
paintball spielen doch ganz normales
blieb spielen also nicht billig sondern
ganz normale street wo man glaube ich
dann eine schaufel und schnee hat also
abbauen das ist ein bisschen viel
genauer als das mit dem mit dem ding
sind das haben wir damals natürlich noch
damals war ich die vier minecraft
gespielter vor 23 jahren oder so da wir
das immer gespielt
vor zwei jahren war das nein kommt geht
es nicht weiter auf mich ich muss jetzt
ein bisschen schneller hier rumlaufen
ich bin im roten lager mann ich will
damit die pflanze läuft und geht einfach
die ganze haus herum und kassiert
einfach kein bisschen genossen der aus
ja genau
gc geht weiter wenn nicht gar nicht
runtergefallen ist der komik hätte
verstehe ich gerade nicht
na gut ich komisch jetzt
warum bleibt die ganze zeit stehen warum
warum ich nehme jetzt auch ein bisschen
an schwung und schob sich nicht wieder
hatten schlugen ihr tag nicht rum
du bist dumm du nicht lukas so schlecht
was kann ich denn dafür dass das hier
alles so hakt wo sind die überhaupt
leute da sein jetzt wieder weg jetzt
verschwindet ihr blauen
guck mal ich schlag in den rhein macht
ihr mal schön das ja auch wieder den
dänen schlagen die anderen das ach so
dass es der gleiche von vorhin ich
dachte die haben leute geschlagen ist es
passiert und man nicht mehr gut
freunde ich glaube das ist einfach nur
unnötig wenn ich jetzt noch
weiterspielen spielprinzip ist nicht so
geil kann man so zwischendurch spielen
wenn ein bisschen frust ablassen muss
aber sonst würde ich euch noch einen
schönen tag mit euch gefallen hat kann
er trotzdem noch mal aufgeben
hier stehen wir beschreiben wir jetzt
beim nächsten mal wieder typisch